hey Ali can we can we talk for a second
her dress
oh my god things is so good you have to
try it oh yeah I get but it's kind of
what I wanted to talk about yeah see
this right here it's not working
and I want you to know that you have a
very special place in my heart but after
this I think she kind of just split wait
yeah
yeah and I thought the Aufbau sorry what
no we're not breaking up and that's that
okay
okay no but seriously you have to try
this
breaking up with someone is probably the
hardest thing I ever had to do
especially when they won't let you David
and I are totally in love I mean how can
I explain this feeling it's like if you
looked up love on Google it would just
be a picture of us kissing nothing can
tear us apart nothing nothing
why do I wanna break up with her let's
see uh for one reason she scares me and
I don't mean that like ah [ __ ] you
scared no she scares me let me tell you
something she yells at me for things
they don't even make sense where are you
going
how did you I didn't give you a key
David don't change the subject where are
you going I'm gonna have dinner with a
friend is that okay with you okay that
doesn't make any sense because didn't
you have dinner yesterday
I believe in positivity if you're not
happy on the outside then you're not
happy on the inside right hey smile a
day could really go a long way way too
positive way too positive I'm not a
negative guy I'm not but let me tell you
something I don't need all that floating
bound in my space if somebody [ __ ] on
this floor right now she would be like
well it's the circle of life
oh my god hey I need you to relax a
little tighter oh I love you too okay
but I'll just come move you flesh out
the oven that's a fleshly cookie there's
a simple rule when it comes to
relationships that all guys should know
about what's mine is mine and what's
yours is ours David agrees mm-hmm hell
no I don't agree is that what she talked
oh she is something else
I let me tell you something my house my
sanctuary you don't touch things in my
house if we're not married
nothing gets moved what the hell is
going on what's what
what what is what is what what wherever
is all my stuff what David I just
rearranged a crazy woman you don't touch
things my sick handle Wow I want
everything back when was biking right
well can you trying to be all assertive
now like a big ol panda bear you're a
big boy now you must be out your
mother's you should know this by now she
knows uh
oh she knows let me tell you you think
I'm crazy I'm not crazy I'm extra pair
oh my god
I'm ever assassinated I know a few
people hey baby yeah no I'm just
thinking of you yeah okay you want to
meet up where that's that sweater I
don't like this one what
it makes my nipples change you don't
want their fabric oh I look Ali look at
me look at me we need to put an end to
this it's over
No
I am self
give your mouth
I don't think the jurors I don't know
don't do that okay
then let go
my god